[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we know cs50 and this is lecture three
and that is not how computer science
works and indeed by the end of the today
we'll make clear
exactly what's right what's not right
about that and hopefully uh
give you some pause anytime you watch tv
or movies hereafter
and notice these little things that all
too many writers seem to take
for granted so recall that last time we
took a look lower level at what
compiling actually is and recall that it
was a few things these four steps of
pre-processing
and compiling and assembling and linking
so that when you start with your source
code
that might look like this code that we
have written in the past you first have
to pre-process it and the first step in
pre-processing was
converting all of those processor
instructions anything starting with a
hash at the beginning
to their equivalent so opening the files
and effectively copying and pasting the
contents there so that programs
and the compiler know what getstring is
and know what printf is
the next step that came after that was
actually compiling whereby compiling
technically means taking that source
code
once it's been pre-processed and
printing and generating this very
cryptic looking stuff
called assembly code and those assembly
codes or assembly instructions
are really what the cpu the brain of
your computer actually understands
although technically the computer
understands them only in the form of
zeros and ones and so when you
assemble step three that assembly code
you actually get out those zeros and
ones but even that simplest of programs
where we just prompt the user for a
string and then print out
their name still involved a couple more
files there is not only cs50.h and cs50
rather and standardio.h at the top
somewhere in the computer system there's
probably files called cs50.c
and in the case of standard io printf.c
in which
actually the code is for those two
functions those two have to get
compiled down to zeros and ones and then
we need to link everything together
merging those zeroes in one so that the
computer has access to your code
and to print f's code and to the cs50
library's code
and so forth but all of that we can just
generally wrap up in the descriptor of
compiling and so that's one of the looks
we took last week and we also have
introduced last week and
previously a few tools and odds are
you're having as many
frustrations perhaps already with the
psets as you are accomplishments and
sense of satisfaction and that's normal
and
rest assured that the the scales will
eventually tip more toward happiness and
away from sadness but will give you
indeed more tools today
than these for actually finding problems
or shortcomings in your code
help50 recall helps with what process
when should you instinctively
consider using help 50 when you see
error messages on the screen something
you don't understand that's the result
of some mistake you probably made
but you don't quite understand what the
computer's telling you run help 50 and
then that same command and we the staff
with our code will try to understand the
message for you and provide you with
feedback
style 50 does exactly that it helps you
see with red and green
color coding exactly what spaces should
be there shouldn't be there it just
helps you pretty your code so that you
can read it better and other humans can
as well
and then printf which is kind of like
the the coarsest tool in your tools
box this is just helping you see not
only messages you want to see but just
the values of variables you can print
ins and strings whatever you want
and then you can delete those lines of
printf once you're confident your
program is working but that gets a
little tedious and honestly as our
programs get bigger
we're going to want more powerful tools
than like manually printing things out
recompiling re-running it very quickly
gets tedious and the goal of programming
is not to be tedious
but to be empowering and that's where
we'll step to today
via this so cs50 ide is sort of a
fancier version of what you've been
using called cs50 sandbox and the turn
cs50 lab now recall that both of those
tools the sandbox and the lab
have a terminal window where you can
type commands they have a code editor
where you can actually
uh run uh type uh write your code
and then they have a file browser with
icons and such where you can actually
see your files
and folders so it turns out that cs50
ide is another tool
that at first glance is very very
similar even though it's laid out a
little differently
but it has as many features as the
sandbox and the lab
but some more more features that
actually help you solve
problems in your code and even
collaborate come final project time with
others if you would like
so this we'll see is the cs50 ide it
comes with the so-called night mode so
you can make everything a little darker
on your screen especially if psetting at
night
and let's actually take a look then at
what you can do with this kind
of tool when you log into this tool for
the very first time in the next problem
set
you'll see an interface that's almost
the same as before the colors are a
little different the font sizes are a
little different but at the bottom by
default you have your so-called terminal
window
though instead of the dollar sign now
you'll see a little more detail
workspace but more on that in a bit up
here you just have the code editor
window nothing's really gone
going on there and then we have the
added feature of ceiling cat in the top
right hand corner
and we'll also see some other features
along the way so let's actually write a
program
in cs50 ide which to be clear is just
another
web-based programming environment that
also gives you access to your own
cloud-based server it too is running
ubuntu linux which is a popular
operating system that is not mac os and
is not windows
but unlike the sandbox environment where
you don't even log in
and you lose your files eventually as
you may know from when your cookies are
lost or something goes wrong
the ide saves everything and you'll log
in with your account and whatever you
put there last week is going to be there
this week and next week
and beyond so let me go ahead up to file
new file
or i could just click this little plus
icon in the top right hand corner
and let me go ahead and preemptively hit
ctrl s or command s
or go to file save you should find the
interface very similar to any mac
or pc program and let me go ahead and
save this file
as follows i'm going to call this hello
dot c and it's important to mention the
file extension otherwise the ide like
the sandbox in the lab won't know what
type of program you're writing
and then let me go ahead and just write
my simplest of programs so let me go
ahead and include standardio.h
int main void let me go ahead then and
open my curly braces printf
hello world backslash n and a semicolon
so you'll notice that almost everything
is the same the colors are
a little different perhaps and you might
see some different assistive features as
you're typing your code but the end
result is the same in the color coding
you just get for free
because it's helping draw your attention
to different parts of the code let me go
ahead now
and oh notice this is one difference the
ide
is a more powerful tool but as such it's
a more manual tool and it's not just
going to auto save your code for you
nice as that's been with the sandbox
such that you've never actually had to
hit command s or control s and if you
were
you didn't need to be this the ide is
only going to save things when you want
it to so that nothing will happen
magically anymore so what i'm going to
have to do is go back up here
file save or command s or control s
you'll see a little green dot
briefly and now i'm back at my prompt
i'm going to go ahead now
and type my familiar command make hello
enter
and you'll see pretty much the same
cryptic looking clang command
as before because the ide is configured
quite like the sandbox
and if i want to go ahead and run this
now how do i run this program
quick check dot slash hello it's exactly
the same as before
dot slash hello and there we have it
hello world so
long story short the user interface thus
far is a little different but
functionally it's the same we're just
gonna now start to see some more
features
so what are those features and let's
introduce a new some capabilities that
were actually possible in the sandbox we
just didn't
really introduce them at the time if i
click this folder icon at top left
you'll see all of my files and folders
and today for lecture i have
a lot of pre-made examples that are
already on the course's website some of
which we'll look at some of which will
defer to the website but these are just
familiar files and folders and you can
see
that everything in my account is
apparently in something called workspace
which is just
a folder name or a directory here's my
source three directory which again comes
from the website for today's
lecture lecture three and then here's
the file i just compiled and the program
and the file that i wrote hello dot c
um you'll notice too that there's this
funky symbol here tilda that you might
not have occasion to write often in
english but in spanish and other
languages you might use this character
this is actually shorthand notation for
what's called your home
directory in this environment cs50 ide
you have your own home directory which
means your
folder of files and other folders that
you get to create you own and that
persists every time you log in you're
not going to lose the contents they're
in
so this just means that in your home
directory
aka tilde there is a folder called
workspace
in which i'm currently working and
that's just one folder in which all of
my work is going to be done
because there's so many other files and
folders in this cloud environment just
like there are in your mac and pc we
just generally don't care what they are
but notice what we can do at this
terminal window besides
write and compile besides compile and
run code
there are other commands for instance
this blue
uh text here similarly to the file
browser up top
indicates now not just that this is my
prompt per the dollar sign
but that i'm in my home directory's
workspace directory so that means i can
be elsewhere
even though i haven't specified where i
want to go yet and in fact i can do this
ls stands for list it's just shorthand
notation for that
and now i see a textual version of my uh
my file tree so to speak so you'll see
here
source three is a folder and you can
tell as much because there's a slash at
the end of it
hello.c is of course the file i wrote a
moment ago and then hello
in green is my program that i compiled
and the star
asterisk there it's just um it's not the
name of the file it's just indicating to
me visually that that is
executable that's a program i can run
just so i know what's compiled and what
maybe is source code
so when you're running dot slash hello
the reason all this time this has been
working
is because in dot your current folder
there is a file called hello and when
you hit enter you are running
that program there so if after today you
go back onto cs50 sandbox or cs50 lab
and type ls you'll see exactly the same
thing as you might via the little folder
icon
in those programs as well but suppose i
want to go into a directory
in a mac os or windows or even the ide i
could of course go my file icon
and then per the little triangle here
which might seem intuitive
you just click it and you can see what's
going on inside not surprising
but how do you do that textually at a
command prompt well it's not all that
hard
you just need to change your directory
so if i do cd
space source 3 enter
nothing seems to happen quite yet except
that my prompt
changed here's the indication that this
is my prompt but to the left of it you
see in blue that i'm now in my home
directories
workspace folder in my source 3 folder
they're in so it's just a text-based
version
of the guise the graphical user
interfaces that all of us have certainly
come to take for granted
in the world of mac os and windows thus
far well suppose that i'm a little uh
done with my hello program and i want to
delete it well in the ide like in the
sandbox you can actually go up here and
you can click on it
and then you can typically right click
or control click and you'll get a whole
menu of other options one of which is
delete
and feel free to tinker like that in
your own environment but what about
the command line if i zoom in down here
and i want to remove
uh hello you're not going to type remove
because that just feels a little verbose
and humans decades ago decided
that's too tedious to type let's just
call this command rm
for remove hello you're going to see a
somewhat cryptic
prompt rm remove regular file hello this
is more arcane than it needs to be but
it's just asking do you
are you sure you want to delete hello
then it's just waiting for you
and here you can type y or yes or
sometimes other commands too now i've
confirmed that my intentions were yes if
i type ls again
whoops in the wrong folder if i type ls
again
after doing hello no after doing hello
and do ls now i'll see just those two
things source 3
and hello dot c what if i want to make a
folder we'll notice this
if i type at the bottom here make
directory
mkdir test just to make a test folder
i'm about to hit enter but watch the top
left hand corner
where i currently have those other files
in folders and when i hit enter
now i have a test folder so these things
are identical one is graphical
one is command line and there's even
other commands if i decide i don't want
that
rmdir is remove directory and it just
goes away
because it's empty and thus safe any
questions then on any of those commands
or just the overall
layout of what it is we're looking at
all right so don't get hung up on any of
those commands and the problem set and
beyond will always remind you of those
kinds of features the point for now is
just that we're in a somewhat new
environment but it's fundamentally
still the same has the same capabilities
so what are other tools we looked at
so you might have heard rumors about a
tool called check50 and indeed this is a
tool that the staff used to evaluate
problem set one and problem set two to
evaluate the quickness of them so that
we ourselves don't have to type dot
slash mario or dot slash caesar
again and again and again to test uh
students code
but starting this week you too have
access to the same program
check50 is a command from the staff that
checks the correctness of your code just
like style 50 checks the
style of your code and in fact if i go
back over to my ide
let's try to use this for the first time
by making the same version of hello that
you did
perhaps for your first problem set so if
i go ahead and include
not just standard io but cs50.h and i go
ahead and get a
string from the user with getstring
prompting them for their name
and then go ahead and print not just
hello world but hello
percent s comma name this i believe
was the same program you yourselves
probably wrote or some variant thereof
so if i go ahead now and test this
myself make hello
enter seems okay dot slash hello
let me go ahead and type in my name and
voila hello david now suppose you're
feeling pretty good you're pretty
confident that your code is correct and
most importantly
you have tested your code yourselves
it's not sufficient to
rely on rtool alone to test your code
because it too might not be exhaustive
so once you've tried a few inputs not
just david but perhaps
veronica's name as well seems to work
brian's name as well
seems to work no name at all doesn't
seem to work maybe but we'll have to
look back to the problem set to see if
that's actually a problem
let me go ahead now and run check 50.
check 50 expects
a special slug so to speak just a unique
identifier for the
problem that you want to check and you
would only know this from reading a
problem set or documentation online
i just happen to recall that the command
that the staff have been using to grade
and evaluate hello is just cs50 slash
2018 slash fall
slash hello and the slashes just kind of
visually distinguish those words this
isn't a folder or files or anything like
that
in your own account so i'm going to run
check 50 cs50 2018
fall hello in the same directory that
hello.c is in
enter it's going to go ahead and connect
to github which is the backend recall
that we use for storing your code it's
authenticating me now which means
what's your username and password i'm
going to go ahead and use one of my test
accounts
and now it's prompting me for my
password and i'm going to go ahead and
type that in you'll notice you're seeing
stars like you see bullets in a website
just so that someone looking over your
shoulder can't see what you're typing
now i'm going to go ahead and watch the
progress it's preparing let me go ahead
and zoom in
dot dot it's looking at my code it's
getting ready for submission it's now
uploading it to github.com and once it's
on the servers then it's going to tell
cs50 server
here is so and so submission go ahead
and run
a few automated tests on it checking
therefore its correctness and hopefully
we're about to see some green happy
smiley faces and voila
yes it looks like this check 50 command
for this problem or
slug so to speak checked that hello.c
exists because if i forgot to
write the file or if i misnamed it
nothing's going to work i if we check
that it compiles successfully so that
too is a happy green face
then it apparently checked what if they
we type in veronica do we see hello
veronica
apparently yes what if we type in
another word brian yes apparently we say
hello brian
and so with high probability we're going
to conclude based on those four
tests that your code is in fact correct
at least with respect to those inputs
and there's often some more detail via
url at the bottom where you can actually
see more graphically just more feedback
on your code
of course the first time second time
third time maybe you run this command
you might not see some green happy faces
you might see some red unhappy faces or
some yellow
flat faces which just means we couldn't
even run the checks because something
else is wrong
but over time this will help you feel
more comfortable and more confident that
your code's correct before you actually
use submit 50
and submit it going into it you'll feel
a little better or a little frustrated
to know
in advance wait a minute i'm about to
submit this but nope it's not yet
correct so realize it's a two-edged
sword any questions about check 50 or
any of these commands thus far
anything at all no all right so let's
take a look at the final
and most powerful tool now available to
you
in the ide environment built into cs50
ide which stands for integrated
development environment which isn't a
cs50 thing this is a common term in
industry for tools
that make it easier to write code it
turns out that there's some other
features besides the cat over here
namely one you can share your workspace
with teaching fellows
and course assistants so that they can
perhaps help you in real time a lot
google docs even chatting with you in
real time
but it also provides you with what's
called a debugger a debugger as the name
suggests
removes bugs or rather helps you remove
bugs from your code
by allowing you to not just resort to
printf printing out ins and strings and
whatever is good that's going on in your
program
it kind of automates that very tedious
process for you and it lets you walk
through your code
one line at a time at your own
comfortable pace
and see along the way all of the values
of your variables
in that program to activate this
debugger i'm going to go ahead and do
the following i'm going to compile my
code
as always with make hello i has to
compile
otherwise i might want to use help50 and
figure out why it's not compiling but it
does seem to have compiled
and now i'm going to go ahead and run
debug 50
space and then the name of the program i
want to debug and the name of the
program i want to debug at the moment is
the current directories file called
hello let's assume that there's perhaps
something wrong with it
the first time i run this command though
debug 50 is not going to be
happy with me because it's going to say
looks like you haven't set any break
points set at least one break point by
clicking to the left of a line number
and then rerun debug 50. well what is a
break point well as the name
kind of suggests it allows you to break
or pause
the running of your code at any of your
lines and all this time for the past few
weeks have your co
has your code been automatically line
numbered and this is useful because
the most interesting line in this
program once it really gets going
isn't the stuff at the top it's not in
main void right that's all
copy paste from past programs it's
really the sixth line here
where i actually have some logic of my
own and so in cs50 ide
what you can now do is click to the left
of one of these line numbers a little
red lie
like a stop sign is going to appear
saying break or pause my program
on this line so that i can poke around
my actual code sandbox and lab cannot do
this
so now i'm going to go ahead and rerun
debug 50 in exactly the same way
hit enter but now i have one break point
and you'll see on the right hand side
a fancier menu just popped up by the cat
that provides me with a bunch of
features and at first glance frankly
it's a little overwhelming because
there's a lot going on here
but you'll notice first and most
importantly
there's some mention of my name variable
i don't quite understand
ox0 or whatnot but i do understand
string and so what the debug 50 program
has realized is oh
on this line and below you have a
variable called name
it doesn't seem to have a value yet ox0
turns out is just going to mean
empty or null or zero but that's good
because now
when i actually execute this line
hopefully it's going to take on the name
david or veronica or brian so let's see
what happens
notice that it's highlighted in yellow
line six which means it has not
yet executed this line of code my code
has broken or paused at this point
because i set that break point
and then notice kind of like a music
player up here
there's a few icons the play button is
just going to say yeah play my program
run it all the way through the end kind
of like scratch with the green flag
but more powerful is this you can step
over this line
therefore executing it just once if it's
a function you can step
into this line and actually look inside
of a function
that you're using like get string or you
can step out of another function but
more on that another time
so what i'm going to do is this the and
the button i'm going to click most
commonly when trying to understand how
my program is working is this
step over so it's the second icon to the
uh
from the left right next to the uh
triangle
so once i click this watch what's going
to happen even though it's a little
small
on the right hand side for my name
variable
notice that i'm being prompted to type
in my name because the program is still
running in my terminal window
but when i hit enter now providing my
own name automatically
you see on the right hand side that this
name variable
has a value now of quote unquote david
of type string there's this ox1083010
more on that later
which is a little cryptic but i didn't
have to use printf now i can actually
see what's going on
now you can see that line seven is
highlighted because i set a breakpoint
above it so now i'm on the second line
because i just stepped into it
let me go ahead and click next again and
you'll see that in my terminal window
hello david just got executed and now if
i just keep going
it's going to go ahead and run to the
end and close the debugger so not all
that useful for this program because
frankly i'm pretty sure this is correct
but the power of debug 50 any debugger
more generally
is that it lets you whether you're less
comfy or more comfy walk through your
own code at your pace just like a tf or
a ca
might say okay what is this line doing
what is this line doing you don't have
to resort to printf
you can just very methodically walk
through your code and find that damn bug
that's been bothering you for minutes or
even hours so henceforth anytime you
have a bug
in your code that is compiling but it's
just logically incorrect the pyramid in
mario isn't quite right your encryption
of caesar isn't quite right or something
else
your first instinct now should be let me
compile it
run debug 50 on it and just step through
the code
setting a break point wherever i want so
you can focus on just a few lines not
the whole thing
like i just did and see if you can
figure out logically when a value is not
what you expect and then oh
go ahead and just click resume fix the
bug and retry
such a powerful tool any questions
yeah what is it
what does it look like when there is a
bug so the debugger won't
find your bugs and it won't show you
your bugs per se it's going to let you
see what line is executing it's going to
let you see what's outputting it's going
to let you take input
but all it's going to do on that right
hand side is just show you the values of
things
along the way it's up to you to infer
from that
information what it is that's going
wrong just like if you were using printf
in past weeks
to see what's going on in your program
other questions
and let me say this too it is so easy to
get into the habit especially when so
many things have been new
over the past few weeks of just saying
ah this is just yet another thing to
learn
this is hands down the kind of tool that
if you spend a few extra minutes this
week and next week just using it get a
little more comfortable with it
it will save you potentially hours in
the long run because all the time you've
been spending manually trying to fix
your bugs
or posting questions online trying to
understand things this is a tool that
you invest those minutes up front
will just help you understand everything
going on inside of your program and will
absolutely over the next few weeks save
you more
and more time alright any questions
ah good question if you have something
like a for loop or a while loop
something that's happening a lot
do you can you set a breakpoint in such
a way that it only breaks
uh so that you don't have to walk
through it a hundred times just to see
that value short answer yes
and let me defer to section and online
resources for just a few of these
features but one you can actually watch
values and you can have what's called a
watch expression
you can say show me this value if only
when
x is greater than 50 or something like
that or you yourself can just add some
lines of code you could add a
if x equals equals 50 then print out
something and you can set a breakpoint
on that new
if temporary line so there's a couple
ways to do that good question to
anticipate yeah
behind
really good question if you're running
debug 50 aren't you adding another
argument
rv per our discussion last week of
command line arguments short answer no
because debug 50 corrects for that so
you don't have to worry about that it
will not shift things over numerically
really good thought other questions
all right so with that said
let's now take some training wheels off
so the only reason i bought these
training wheels years ago was to make
this very dramatic point
of now taking the training wheels off
today
okay so what does this mean well worth
the trip to target
so what does this mean for the past few
weeks we have been using a whole bunch
of
functions from cs50s library all of
these were meant to just make it pretty
easy relatively speaking in the first
few weeks
to get input from the user because it
turns out as we'll see today it's
actually a
kind of a pain in the neck to get input
from users in
c and frankly even in other languages
reliably because you'll recall that get
string and get into all these functions
take on the burden of like reprompting
the user if they don't actually give you
an int or don't give you a float or
don't give you a char that you're
expecting
they'll reprompt they're using a while
loop or do while loop or the like so
there's just a lot of error detection
built into these functions
but most importantly and most
misleadingly
has been the last one on this list
recall that we introduced a couple weeks
ago now
the notion of a string and a string is
in english what
an array of characters good it's a
sequence of characters and we learned
last week that a sequence can be
implemented in an array which is just a
chunk of memory back to back to back to
back
so string though is not quite like
any of those other data types it turns
out that it's not quite like int
or char or even bool or float and we can
start to see that now
as follows i'm going to go ahead and go
into the ide today and henceforth we're
going to just start using the ide but
you're welcome
to keep using the sandbox for quick and
dirty programs but for anything you want
to keep around
your instinct should now be to open your
ide i'm going to go ahead and create a
new
file and i'm going to call it compare 0
dot
c for my first example of comparing
things and i'm going to go ahead and
whip up a
relatively short program that you would
hope would work right out of the box so
i'm going to go ahead and include the
familiar cs50.h
i'm going to go include standardio.h i'm
going to go ahead and do int main void
i'm going to go ahead and adhere let me
get a variable called i
using getint from the user and just
prompt them for i
let me go ahead then and prompt the user
for another get int we'll call it
j and get that from them and then let's
just compare these things so if i
equals equals j then go ahead and print
out with printf
same and a new line then go ahead
and print out the opposite which is
different
so the only place i think i could have
screwed up perhaps is if i did this
which is kind of reasonable if you come
in knowing what an equal sign is but
again in code
we typically need two equal signs
because that compares two values so
i didn't make that mistake i'm feeling
pretty good about this let me save it
with command s or control s or via file
save
go to my prompt and run make compare
zero good
everything compiled and let me go ahead
and run compare 0
enter and i'll type in 50 and i'll type
in 50
and they do seem to be the same let me
go ahead and do that again let's type in
42
and 13 and they are different and i
should probably test a few more maybe
some negative values maybe some zeros
positive values and like but i'm feeling
pretty good about the correctness of
this code
all right so let's change this program a
bit let me go ahead and create another
file which i can do with the little
green plus or via file new file
i'm going to go ahead and save this one
as compare 1 dot c
and for the moment i'm going to go ahead
and just paste in that code
from before but i'm going to make some
changes now i'm going to go ahead and
rename
and retype my fi my data types as string
so give me a string called
s and we'll prompt the user for that
using get string
then i'm going to go ahead and change
this one to string t
and go ahead and get get string i of
course need to now compare s and t
not i and j and s is a common variable
name for a string t just comes after s
so that's pretty reasonable too
but i should of course update that as
well and so i think everything's now the
same logically i just changed my data
types and my variable names
so i've saved this let me go ahead and
run make compare one
good everything's correct let me go
ahead and do dot slash
um compare one let me go ahead and type
in
uh brian and veronica and of course
those are different now let me go ahead
and type in david
let me type in david again and those of
course
are different huh maybe it's
maybe i just hit the spacebar or
something so let's try um
let's try erin her name is a little
shorter
okay let's try oh what's your name tj
okay even shorter perfect tj can't go
wrong different i mean what is going on
let's just say
i i different
so where's the logical bug in this
program
what is it that's going on yeah what do
you think
is it comparing integer values well
maybe i mean thus far when we've used
equal equals we've probably used it
mostly for comparing integers so maybe
i'm just misusing it
sure other thoughts
oh that's a big word that we'll get to
in just a little bit but correct uh
correct
but for very similar reasons so it's
something's going
on logically involving comparison
because i'm using equal equal but maybe
i'm
using it for the wrong data types i mean
it's clearly broken
for strings so why might that actually
be
well it turns out that strings don't
actually
exist so a string that we know is just a
sequence of characters or an array of
characters
is not an actual data type int is float
is double
is long is bool is and even more are
actual data types
string is kind of a little white live
we've been telling for a few weeks
that's implemented only in the cs50
library now the word string is super
common in programming like every
programmer out there will know what you
mean when you say straight that is not a
cs50 word
but our use of it in c is cs50 specific
because in that file called cs50.h in
addition to declaring functions like
getstring and getint and getflowed and a
bunch of other things
we also have a special line that says
create a data type
called string but what does it actually
do or what does it actually mean well
let's go ahead and consider
what might be going on underneath the
hood here so if i go ahead
and draw the program that we just ran
that program compare1 gets a string s
from the user then gets a string t
from the user and then compares them so
we know from last week what a string is
it's just an array
so when i run that first line of code
and get a string from the user for
instance brian
i'm going to go ahead and see a b r i a
n which we know from last week to
actually be
an array of memory that might look
pictorially like this and this too is a
bit of a white lie there's something
else
yeah the null character so to speak and
ul which we typically just write with a
backslash zero
which is just all zero bits and it turns
out you might recall from the debugger
earlier you saw this
that's the even more cryptic way of
expressing the null character backslash
zero just different programs display it
in different ways so when i get string
and type in brian
this is what's allocated in memory and
when i type veronica
i get c v e r o n i
c a i'm going to get that right
preemptively backslash zero
that too is a chunk of memory which i'll
draw like this
one two and split these up into interval
characters or
bytes and recall from last time that
these bytes just come from my memory
and that memory just has a bunch of
bytes in it maybe millions or even
billions these days
and so honestly if you just have that
many things any human or computer can
certainly number them
like this is byte 1 2 3 4. so let's just
assume for the sake of discussion
that out of context of my computer's
hardware brian just ended up at location
100 and location 101
and 102 103 104
105. so this is the 100th byte in my
computer this is 105th byte in my
computer and brian is using that many
characters in total
veronica she ended up somewhere else
maybe she ended up farther away
just because at location 900 901
902 903 904
905 906 lot more memory 907
and 908 but you can see even more
visually now that the length of brian's
name
stur lang of brian is what
i hear five and i hear six the length of
brian's name hi brian how long is your
name
okay it is definitively five characters
that is the length of brian's name but
you have to appreciate that in the
computer brian's five character name
does indeed take up six bytes so both
answers are kind of correct
but the length of the string henceforth
is always the number of actual
characters
the amount of space it takes up is that
plus one for the null character so you
can actually see
why brian's name takes up six bytes in
this picture rather than just
the actual length which is five so when
you call getstring now
and when you call getstring and get
another string brian and veronica
respectively
what is actually being handed back a
couple weeks ago aaron came up and she
kind of they handed me back a string a
student's name from the audience
and on that piece of paper we thought
was the student's name but it's not it
turns out that when a function returns a
value
it can pretty much only return a one
byte or maybe two or four bytes
it can't return an arbitrary number of
bytes like six for brian or
one two three four five six seven eight
nine it cannot return
nine bytes for veronica and if you even
type a whole paragraph or
page of text it can't return all of that
text it can only return
a single value so to your instinct
earlier
what might actually be getting returned
by get string
when the human has typed in a name like
brian or veronica
the memory location indeed in integer or
as you called it a pointer
which we'll introduce more formally in
just a moment so when getstring returns
brian quote-unquote it's actually not
returning b-r-i-a-n
backslash zero it is just returning 100
and when get string returns veronica
it's not returning her name it's
returning
900. and so if you realize that now
when you do does s equal equal t what
question
more mundanely are you actually asking
yeah memory location of memory location
does 100 equal 900 and
obviously not and so that is why brian's
name veronica's name my name
tj's name every word i typed in was of
course different
because each input was ending up at a
different location in memory and even if
i typed the same word like david twice
one david was going here one david was
going somewhere else they were ending up
at different memory locations maybe 100
maybe 900
maybe something else but they were
ending up in different locations in
memory
so equals equals does compare values but
damn it if it isn't
comparing the wrong values yeah
ah so come back to that let me come back
to that in just a moment char star is
actually
integrally related more on that in a
moment yeah
really okay really good question so wait
a minute this same
logic that i'm returning the address of
something
surely applies to integers as well or
floating point values as well because
if i type in the number 50 like i did
earlier that too
is somewhere in memory like a box in
memory and that too has an address
somewhere in memory but it turns out for
reasons that you just alluded to
actually
ints are returned as their values chars
are returned as their values
bools are returned as their values
floats or returned as their values
strings are different strings are
returned by their
address and those addresses it turns out
uh do are ultimately going to be called
char stars which we'll see in just a
moment so how do we go about then
fixing this fundamentally like even if
you have no idea how to code this yet
just intuitively
if i do actually want to delete uh if i
do actually want to compar
compare sorry
okay if i do want to go ahead and
compare brian and veronica
for equality what do i want to do
intuitively
i can't just compare their addresses
what do i need to do
isolate the characters and then do what
with them
good yeah good instincts use a for loop
use a while loop any kind of looping
structure
and intuitively compare the first
characters and if they're different well
then we know we don't have to go any
further
b is not a v so surely these names are
different but what about in my case if
it was david and david you would compare
the first two
d and d are the same compare the second
two a and a are the same
v and v i and i d and d and then what am
i going to hit last
null character and should i keep going
beyond the null character
no so this is the beauty of that super
simple design for a string
insofar as strings are identified
by their starting address just the bite
at which they start
you still need to know how long they are
because otherwise how do you know where
one word begins and ends
and another word begins and so the
simple decision we made last week as did
humans decades ago
to terminate all strings with backslash
zero or all zeros
is a super handy trick so that if i tell
you that brian starts at 100
you can infer that he ends where
at byte number 105 or 104 if you will
however you want to think about it
because
all you need to do in linear time if you
will left to right
is check backs out shareback session ah
backslash zero now i know how long
brian's name is
so let's consider for a moment this
program called string length
how does sterling actually work when you
pass to sterling
a variable containing a string like
brian what is sterling probably doing
exactly it's looking at that null
character's address
and subtracting the start address and
the end address
figuring out what the difference is and
actually returning that
minus one as the total count and more
mechanically we'll see in a moment it's
probably doing exactly the same thing i
did which is
is this backslash arrows this backslash
zero is this is this is this
i asked that question five times before
i saw backslash zero
sterling is just a function some human
wrote years ago
that probably just has a simple for loop
and an if condition and then
that's it because that person understood
before we even did
how strings are actually implemented
any questions then all right so let's
actually implement this
let me go ahead and into my editor here
and make one other example here that i'm
going to call compare
two i'm gonna go ahead and do include
cs50.h
and include standardio.h and then i'm
gonna do
int main void and i'm going to quickly
now
grab my code from before where i got
strings
and i compared them but i have to
obviously fix that comparison so here's
my code from before
i'm going to do this the right way i'm
going to call a function called compare
strings passing in s and t because as
you proposed we need to do some logic
we don't have to pass it to a function
but we could we could just do a for loop
here but i'm going to go ahead and
implement compare strings as follows
if i want to write a function that
returns a yes no answer
what data type should it return
a bool so we've not necessarily done
this yet but you can return a bool just
like you can in int
or char or something else i'm going to
call this function compare strings
it's going to take in one string call it
a and another string called b
but i could call those anything i want
and now what's the easiest thing
to check if i'm past two strings a and b
or brian and veronica
what's the easiest question you can ask
and just immediately say nope these are
different
string length right like if b-r-i-a-n
does not it does not have the same
length as veronica's name
we don't need to do any logic whatsoever
beyond that we can just quit and say
false so let me just do that if the
sterling of a
does not equal the sterling of b you
know what let's just go ahead
and return false and get out of here
okay but now
if we get past that gateway so to speak
that check that question that boolean
expression
now i have to compare things character
by character by character
so i can do this in a bunch of ways but
i like the suggestion of a for loop so
4 int i gets 0 n for efficiency
actually let's do i is less than the
string length of
should i do the string length of a or b
it doesn't matter right so let's go with
a and frankly had i been smart early on
i could have stored the value in a
variable and then reused it but we'll
just keep going ahead for now
then i plus plus but i remember from
last time this is correct this is not
good design
why
yeah i keep calling sterling again and
again because remember in a for loop
this condition is checked again
and again and again you're just wasting
your own time so let me go ahead and
actually do this
n or any variable equals the sterling of
a
then just compare i against n because
now i
is getting incremented but n is never
changing so now let me go ahead and
implement this for loop
so if how about the ith character of a
does not equal the i character of b
i can immediately conclude nope these
strings can't be the same because some
letter like a b
is not the same as another like a v or
whatever letter we're actually comparing
and then i think that's it if i get
through these gauntlets
of questions are your links different
are your characters different and i
still haven't said
false what should i return by default
yeah like if you make it through all of
those questions and all as well
then dav id must indeed equal dav id
or whatever the user actually typed in
now i'm not quite done yet
when i've implemented a function or
helper function like this because it's
helping me do my work
what else do i have to add to the file
sure if you just type in david
and then david lower casey you're going
to run because they're not getting the
same because your first character
correct so this is a feature not a bug
at the moment
my program at the moment is case
sensitive if i type in david in all caps
that is a different string i claim for
now
than david in all lower case if you want
to tolerate uppercase and lowercase
you're gonna have to add more logic
but for now that's a that's a design
decision that i intend
all right what else do i need to add to
the program
yeah the prototype at top so you can
literally copy and paste this the only
time copy and paste is probably a
legitimate thing to do
at the top and then semicolon don't
re-implement it but i do need one other
header file
i'm using a function that's not in
cs50.h
or in standardio.h
string length where was string length
yeah string.h so i just need this
include string.h
save now if this i think is correct
we'll see if i eat that word in a moment
but realize that if you're writing this
code yourself like this is not a natural
thing to be writing a program in office
hours or at home in your dorm and just
getting it right the first time this is
after like 20 years of doing this
so realize we happen to be and i also
have a cheat sheet right here
we happen to be doing this correctly
often but realize that's not going to be
the common case
so with that reassurance in mind let's
see if i've
now take all that back make compare two
okay 20 years worked out so now i'm
gonna go ahead and do dot slash compare
two let's type in brian let's type in
veronica
those are indeed still different
hopefully now let's try myself
david and david those are the same and
to your point
david in uh capitalized and david in all
lowercase
different but that's what i expect now
any questions uncompared to yeah
okay
if you were to hard code the strings
short answer yes that would still work
if you for whatever reason
did not do this and using getstring but
you did david
and here for instance david that would
work too
and whatever your areas if you can
recreate it just let us know
i'd have to see it to be sure but happy
to chat after all right so
let's see if we can't now clean this up
just a little bit
um as follows let me go ahead here
and reveal what it is that's actually
going on
so indeed there is no such thing as a
string and indeed as you pointed out a
moment ago it actually goes by a
different name
string is just a synonym for what's
called a char
star now what does that even mean so
char is the same as it's always been
it's a single character
star in a program uh written in c could
of course mean multiplication we have
seen that this is another use of the
star
whenever you see it after a data type
like char
this means that the data type in
question is not just a char
it's the address of a char so the star
just means the address of whatever the
data type is to the left and this is as
you pointed out earlier
what we're going to start calling a
pointer a pointer is for all intents and
purposes
an address it's just a buzzword to
describe an address
this data type here char star means i
want a variable
that doesn't store a char it stores the
address of a char
the number 100 the number 900 but
that address is just going to be called
a pointer a pointer variable is a
variable that stores the address
of something a char or even other data
types as well
so with that in mind let me actually
quickly create compare
3.c paste this in
and save it as compare 3.c and let me
take off
if you will those training wheels it
turns out that when you get a string
with getstring it doesn't return a
string per se because again that
word doesn't exist in c it actually
returns a char
star and when i call it again here and
return another string
it too returns a char star now
technically the star can have spaces
around it some people write it like this
but the sort of right way to do it or
the default way should just be to put
the star
next to the variable name for clarity so
i have to make a few other changes
this should change too because there is
no more string as of today
i'm going to change this to a char star
and then i also need to change it here
char star and then here char
star and that is actually it
and honestly the only reason we didn't
introduce this like
two weeks ago is because it just looks
cryptic like no one wants to program the
first time they're ever touching a
keyboard and writing code and see char
star
need to worry about what that means it's
just a string conceptually
but the only change i technically need
to mean to take those training wheels
off
is just change all mentions of string as
data types
to char star and that just means that
you know what a yes it's a string
but more technically it's the address of
a string
or more precisely it is the address of
the first
byte of the string like a hundred for
brian or 900 for veronica
and i'm not even going to tell you where
the string ends because you
the programmer can figure that out by
calling sterling or just by using a loop
and figuring out where that backslash
zero
actually is so that is enough
information to pass it around so if i go
ahead now and compile this
make compare 3 and then i go ahead and
do
dot slash compare 3 let's go ahead and
type in brian
and veronica those are indeed still
different now let me go ahead and type
in david
and david those are in fact the same so
the training wheels are off there is no
such thing as string
henceforth it's a char star let's go
ahead and take a quick break here for
five minutes
and we'll come back and dive in more
alright
so we are back and let's go ahead and
simplify this now as our tendency has
been it's kind of a bunch of code but i
think we can make this a little tighter
but rather than type this one out
manually let me go ahead and just open
one of our pre-made examples from today
which is all on the course's website
called compare four
and you'll see in compare four that's it
i only have a main function this time
i've gotten rid of my compare strings
function because you know what
i seem to be using something instead
what function did i apparently deploy
yeah str cmp or someone would pronounce
it just stir compare or stir comp
so this like sterling also succinctly
named
is just a function that's actually
declared in one of our familiar
libraries up top string.h
and it turns out if you look in the man
page so to speak by typing man
stir comp or if you go to cs50 reference
and actually look at the less
comfortable description of the function
there this is just a function whose sole
purpose in life is to
compare strings for you but it's a
little different in behavior
because it's a little fancier than the
one i just wrote let me zoom in on this
and you'll see that on line 14 here i'm
not
quite treating it in the same way
my logic is ever so slightly different
what am i actually checking for in my
boolean expression this time
yeah which is a little weird i'm
checking explicitly is stir compares
return value equal equal to zero before
i just said
if compare strings s comma t
because i was expecting back a bull true
or false stir compare
kind of weirdly acts the opposite way it
turns out that stir compare
doesn't return true and false if you
read its documentation it returns
zero if the strings are equal but super
conveniently
it returns a positive value if s
is supposed to come before t and it
returns a negative value
if s is supposed to come after t
alphabetically
so it turns out that you can use stir
compare not just compare for equality
but inequality
less than or equal less than or greater
than so to speak
alphabetically or in ascii order so to
speak it will actually compare character
by character
the ascii values and that will make sure
that b comes after a
and c comes after b and so forth so you
can actually use stir compare to like
sort a dictionary or to sort
the contacts in your iphone your android
phone so long story short
this is a function we can use we don't
have to reinvent this wheel
and thus we have no more code even after
this we just have to use it correctly
and there
the documentation is your friend so if i
run this program it's going to work
exactly the same way
but let me go ahead and point out some
flaws it turns out all this time
i've been a little lazy with my error
checking checking for errors
there's a whole bunch of things that can
go wrong in week one of cs50 that we
just kind of turn a blind eye to because
it would just bloat our code make it
longer and sort of less interesting and
fun to write
and less comprehensible but today now
that we know what's actually going on we
can begin to ask some additional
questions and make our code stronger
more robust so that nothing does in fact
go wrong
turns out if you read the documentation
for get string in the man page or on
cs50 reference
turns out getstring does return a string
not really
it returns the address of a string not
really it returns the address
of the first byte of a string
technically but if something goes wrong
it returns a special
character called null not to be confused
with nul
it returns a special address called
n-u-l-l
left-hand wasn't talking to right hand
decades ago so null n-u-l-l
just means the address zero which
nothing should ever live at it's just a
bogus invalid address
so in so far as getstring returns
the address of a string in memory like
100 for brian
or 900 for veronica if getstring ever
runs into a problem and just something
goes wrong with the computer
if it ever returns zero specifically
zero
um aka null and ull
then you can detect that something has
gone wrong
so to do that and it's going to get a
little tedious but it's nonetheless the
right thing to do
i need to be a little more defensive if
s equals equals null otherwise known as
zero
otherwise known as ox0 but i'll write it
conventionally like this
i'm going to go ahead and return 1 as my
exit code
if t equals equals null i'm going to go
ahead and return 1 as my exit code or i
could return
2 or 3. i just need to return some value
to signal
to the computer that something went
wrong but by default we'll just return
one when everything
whenever something goes wrong but if all
went well i'm going to go ahead and
return 0. so recall again from last week
and we didn't spend a huge amount of
time on this
main itself can return values by default
ever since week 1
if you don't return anything maine is
automatically and secretly returning 0
for you because zero
is good the reason for zero is because
there's only one zero in the world
obviously but there's an infinite
numbers to the left and there's an
infinite numbers to the right
negative and positive that's great
because as you've already experienced in
the past few weeks it feels like there's
an infinite number of things that can go
wrong when you're writing even the
shortest of programs so that means we
have a lot of numbers
we can assign to error codes so to speak
now i don't really care what the error
codes are
so i'm just going to adopt the human
convention at the moment if anything
goes wrong
return anything other than zero and so
i'm going to return one up here but if
nothing goes wrong
return zero the point here is that by
adding
these three lines here and these three
lines here
i'm going to avoid what's called a
segmentation fault or seg fault and
did any of you encounter this cryptic
error okay so a decent number of you and
if you probably had no idea what that
means but starting today you will
a bit more and in the weeks to come
you'll understand it even more
segmentation fault means you touched
memory
you should not have and or something
went wrong and you did not detect it
it's kind of a catch-all phrase for
memory related problems
this helps ward off those kinds of
errors it's not the only way
but it's one such way so starting today
with problem set programs and anything
you write in the course
you always want to be thinking about
even if you go back and add it later
could this go wrong could this go wrong
could this go wrong and just add some
additional ifs and elseifs
and handle those situations so that your
program doesn't just crash on you or seg
fault
or surprise someone who's actually using
it all right let's take a look at one
final example because frankly this is a
little tedious i'm going to go ahead and
open up
and this file can be found in compare 5
dot c let me go ahead and save this
so that we have it compare 5 dot c i'm
going to make one final comparison
example i'm going to save this as
compare 6
dot c turns out that humans like their
succinctness
and null because it is technically the
zero address
you can actually be a little clever if
not
s and if not t is a sufficient way to
express those same things because what
does
the bang do the exclamation point in
code if you recall
it inverts something so like if this is
saying
if s is not 0 aka if s is not
null or rather then
if now i'm getting confused yes
if i had just said if s then it's a
valid address and i should go on with my
business
but if it's not s or if s
is null i want to go ahead and return
one because there's an error and down
here too so anytime you're
checking to whether something equals
null you can make it more succinct by
just saying if not
s if it's null return one if it's null
return one it's just
uh syntactic uh shorthand
i had to think about that one any
questions
correct you are storing an address but
if that address
is zero saying if it's not zero
zero is like false so not false means
true and so it has the effect of
inverting the logic
that's all anytime you use a bang or
exclamation point it changes a zero to
non-zero
so you can think about it this way if s
previously we had this
if s equals equals null is like saying
if s literally equals zero and you can
kind of think of that informally as
if s doesn't have a valid pointer zero
is not a valid pointer it's not a valid
address by definition
100 is valid 900 0 is not valid just by
human convention
so this is like saying if s does not
have a value
that's valid so the way to succinctly
say that
if uh not s
and it's just shorthand for that is
another way to think about it all right
so let's take a look
at a very different program but that
reveals the same kind of issue
as follows i'm going to go ahead and
open up an example called copy zero
whose purpose in life hopefully is to
copy a string
so notice that in my program here which
i wrote in advance
i'm getting a string from the user on
line 11 and i'm storing it in a string
called s i could change this to char
star now but
we know what it is and now i'm going to
go ahead and copy the string's address
from s into t and then i'm going to say
if the length of t is greater than zero
then go ahead and just capitalize the
first character so it's a little cryptic
but you might have done something kind
of like this with caesar and with recent
string manipulation
this is just making sure do i have at
least one character and if so
first character is t bracket zero as you
recall two upper is a function in c
type dot a it's from last week that just
capitalizes this letter so this one line
of code 19
just capitalizes the first letter in t
that's it and then at the very end we
just print out what s is and print out
what t
is that's all so this program just
copies s into t
capitalizes t and that's it so let me go
ahead and make
copy zero this is in our code from today
so i'm going to do cd
source 3 because i already wrote it in
that directory make copy 0
went well dot slash copy 0.
let's go ahead and type in tj again
in lowercase enter
tj tj both are capitalized all right
maybe it's just a weird thing with
initials so
let's just do uh veronica all lowercase
huh that's definitely capital let's do
even more obvious difference brian where
the b
is really going to look different yet
i'm
only capitalizing t well let's consider
what's actually going on here in this
case
when i'm getting a string from the user
s and t
and i type in for instance brian in all
lowercase backslash zero this of course
is just an array
underneath the hood uh this is taking up
six bytes here
and when i store an s s is a string so
you know what like we didn't do this
before
let me actually create a variable a
chunk of memory for s
and call it s and suppose brian is just
where he was before
100 101 102 103
104 105. so if i do
s equals get string and get string
returns brian what do i write in the box
called
s yeah just 100 right this is all that's
been going on all this time even though
we didn't talk about it
at this level and actually it turns out
pointer actually can be used pictorially
if you actually prefer to think about a
pointer as being an address or like kind
of a map that leads you somewhere
another way a human would typically draw
a pointer because honestly who really
cares that brian is at address 100 like
that is way too low level that's like
weak zero
stuff you know he's just pointing there
so s is a pointer to that chunk of
memory it happens to be 100 whatever
the arrow is how you would literally
point at the chunk of memory if you were
drawing this on some notes
so that too is correct so the problem
arises here
with that line of code when i actually
try to copy
s and store in t think about what's
going on the right hand side is just s's
value which
happens to be a hundred the left
left-hand side is just saying hey
computer
give me another variable for a string
and call it t
so that's like saying hey computer give
me another chunk of memory
call it t and then store s init but what
does it mean to store s well what is s's
value at this point in time
it's the pointer to brian or it's
technically all right both just for
thoroughness
it's literally the number 100. so if you
do t
equals s that is like saying put 100
there too
and pictorially that's like saying this
so at this point in the story
when i copied s into t the computer took
me
literally it did copy s into t but what
is s
it's just the address it is not b r i a
n backslash zero
it's just the address so when i then say
t bracket zero gets to upper so let's
look at this line of code
the one line of code here that's
highlighted when i say go to the zeroth
character of t
and store the uppercase version of that
same character
you just follow the arrows if you ever
played shoots and ladders as a kid just
kind of follow the arrow see where you
end up
t bracket 0 is this location here
because again
if this is a chunk of memory per last
week it's an array so you can also think
of this as being bracket zero
this is bracket one this is bracket two
and so forth so it's just an array so
t bracket zero is lowercase b
and two upper of lowercase b of course
changes this little b
to a big b but now both s and t are
still pointing at the same chunk of
memory so of course
s and t are both going to be brian
capitalized or tj2
in my first example any questions then
on what we just did and why that
happened
all right so intuitively what's the fix
doesn't matter if you have no idea how
to code it like what do we have to do to
fundamentally copy a
string not an address
create a new what
yeah create the same string in a new
chunk of memory what i really need to do
is
allocate or give myself a bunch of more
memory
that's just as big as brian including
his backslash zero and then logically i
just need to copy
every character into that so if i go
back to my original when it was a
lowercase b
i need to make a copy logically by using
a for loop or a while loop or whatever
you prefer
b r i a n backslash zero
so that when i copy the string and then
store
it in t it's not actually copying
literally s and let's suppose
that he ends up at location 300 just
arbitrarily does just making up easy
numbers
t now stores 300 points here
so when i execute this line in this
version of the story
t bracket zero gets too upper what am i
actually doing
i'm following a different arrow this
time because i gave myself a different
chunk of memory
capitalizing this brian thereby
hopefully
fixing the bug albeit verbally only
so how do we do this in code we need to
do exactly that we need to give
ourselves some more memory
so let's introduce one other feature of
c
in copy one dot c we see the solution to
this problem notice at the top
i'm doing things a little lower level
surprise
notice in this version of the code
copy1.c
i've started off almost the same but
just to be super clear
i'm just using char star i don't want
any magic so there's no string there's
no training wheels here
but this logically is the exact same as
before plus the error checking
this line is new and it looks a little
funky but let's see what
what's going on and this line of code
here
what am i doing the left hand side
that's shorter let's start with the
easier one
char star t just in layman's terms what
does that
expression do char star t hey computer
do what good what's that
not quite yet different formulation
hey computer give me an equate
be more precise
uh not quite an array just this part so
let me hide all this
if the star wasn't there i can't really
do this very well so
this oh yeah good i'll take that so hey
computer give me
a pointer to a character or even more
low level hey computer
give me a chunk of memory in which i can
store the address
of a character i mean it is that mundane
draw a box on the screen
call it s or rather call it t but just
give me space
for a pointer as you say so that's all
that's doing it's drawing a box on the
screen
and calling it t and it's currently
empty now let's look at the scarier part
on the right hand side
malloc new function today stands for
memory allocates it's very cryptic
sounding but it just means give me a
chunk of memory it says exactly what you
said
in functional terms then it just asks
needs you to answer one question
okay how much memory do you want how
many bytes do you want
and now maybe the math even though
cryptic at first glance makes sense
get the string length of s add one
and then multiply it by the size of a
character and we've not seen this before
sizeof literally does that it tells you
how many bytes
is a char happens to be one and in fact
that's defined
so if we simplify this in c the char is
always one byte
so this is equivalent to just
multiplying by one and obviously
mathematically that's a waste of time
so we can whittle this down to be even
simpler i was just being thorough
so now hey computer allocate me
this many bytes of memory why is it plus
one
i need that null character brian is one
two three four five as he said but i
need the sixth
for his null character and i just know
that's going to be there so at this
point in the story what has happened
all malloc does all that malloc does
is it gives me this box of memory
containing room for as many bytes as in
brian's name but it doesn't fill them
just yet
now i need to logically fill those bytes
with brian's actual name
so if we scroll down to my for loop here
we can actually
copy the string into that space and it's
a little long the expression but nothing
new here
initialize i to zero n to the length of
s
uh i is less than or equal to n we'll
come back to that i plus plus
so it's just a pretty standard for loop
then copy the ith character of s
into the eighth character of t the only
thing that's making me a little nervous
honestly is this thing here
like i feel like every time we do less
than or equal to we create a bug like
last week
but this is correct why
why do i want to go up to and through
the length of
this exactly because of the null
character i actually don't want to stop
at the sterling of s so i could change
this if you're just more comfortable
using
less than because you just got your mind
wrapped around while we do that in the
first place
that's fine we just need to do this
instead
so this is mathematically if you go to
string length plus one
the same thing as not doing that math
but just going one step further just
whatever you want to think about it is
fine however you want to think about it
is fine okay and then lastly
just a quick check is the length of t at
least one or more characters because
otherwise there's nothing to capitalize
and if so
go ahead and do it so if i now run this
example make oop let me save it
make copy one that compile dot slash
copy one
now let's type in tj tj and lowercase
comes back but now t is capitalized and
let's go ahead and do brian's name
in all lower case only one of them is
now capitalized
so does that make sense what's now
happened
all right so where can we go with this
well it turns out let me open up one
final example here because honestly
that's incredibly tedious and no one's
ever going to want to copy strings if
you have to go through all of that work
turns out that stir copy exists
so when in doubt check the man page when
in doubt check cs50 reference does a
function exist
somewhere related to some keywords you
have in mind like string
copy see if something comes back and
indeed we've had stur lang we've had
stir compare we now have stir copy
and if you read the documentation this
is deliberately reversed like this
the destination is this variable the
source or the origin string is this one
and it copies from one
into the other and then i don't need
that while loop that for loop it just
saves me a few
lines of code all right so let's take
off
one other detail here oh and you'll
notice actually
let me make one fix one fix here
it turns out that what i'm doing here is
a little lazy
it turns out that malloc does have an
opposite
so anytime you allocate memory
technically you should also be
freeing that memory and so c allows you
to ask the computer for as much memory
as you want but if you never give it
back have you ever experienced on your
own mac or pc
like after your computer's been running
a while or using some new or bloated
program like a browser
it gets slower and slower and slower and
in the worst case it just freezes or
hangs or something it is quite possible
that that program simply was made by
humans of course
just has a memory leak so some human
wrote one or more lines of code that
uses malloc or some equivalent in
another language that just kept
allocating memory for the user's input
you're visiting one web page two web
pages that requires memory whatever the
program is
and if that human never calls the
opposite of allocate
deallocate otherwise known as free
you're never giving the memory back to
the operating system so it gets slower
and slower because it's running lower
and lower and lower on memory
and it might have to move some things
around to make room for things that's
what's called a memory leak
and so indeed in this program i should
actually improve this a little bit if i
go back into this version here
and on line 18 recall i allocated this
memory just to make my copy
the very last thing i should actually do
in this program
is this line here free you don't have to
tell the computer how many bytes you
want to free it will remember for you
so long as you just pass in the pointer
the variable
that's storing the address of the chunk
of memory
that you allocated all right so let's
now see
why we've been using getstring since
it's not just to kind of simplify the
code it's also to defend against some
very easy problems
here is a program called scanf0 scan
formatted text another arcane sounding
function but it's pretty straightforward
this program simply gets an int from the
user using scanf
up until now for the past three weeks
you've used get int so this is an
alternative to get int
that you could have started using a few
uh weeks ago
give me an int called x print out x
colon whatever that's just the prompt to
the user
scanf percent i ampersand x
semicolon whatever that is and then
print out x's value using percent i
so what's going on here now today we can
actually start to wrap our minds around
what get in
actually does this is effectively get in
if you actually look at the source code
forget it it's a little fancier
but in essence what getint does is it
declares a variable
called x and it doesn't put anything
there because that's supposed to come
from you the human
it then prompts you for whatever string
you pass to get in so those are the
first two lines
and this is the only weird looking one
scanf is like the opposite of printf
you still use a formatted string percent
s percent i
percent f or whatever but
you're not going to output this you're
going to input this from the human's
keyboard
and ampersand x is the opposite
of uh is the is the special symbol in c
that says go ahead and get me the
address
of x so don't pass in x give me the
address of x
now why is that we'll see but this is
the way where you can tell the computer
i've made a variable for you called x
here is where it is it's a treasure map
that leads you to x
go put a value here for me and so the
end result is that we do in fact end up
getting an end if i do make scan f0
and then dot slash scan f0 i'll type in
42.
all right it's not an interesting
program it just spits back out what i
got
but that's literally all that git int of
course is doing if you then print out
the value
so if i stipulate this is correct this
is how you get an end from the user but
honestly the reason we don't do this in
week one of the course is like
my god we just took the fun out of even
getting a simple number from the user by
using these lines of code and whoever
knows what this symbol is we don't want
you to think about that
we want you to just get an int but today
those training wheels are off
but we're going to run into a problem
super fast
let's try the same thing with a string
if i were to
do this you would think that the result
is the same
or let's just do it as char star but
there's going to be one tweak
if i go ahead and give myself space
for the address of a character i don't
need to use the ampersand now
because scanf does need to be told where
the chunk of memory is
but it's already an address so i don't
need the ampersand here
recall earlier i declared into x which
was just an int
ampersand x gets the address of that end
here
i'm saying from the get-go give me the
address of a char
i don't need the ampersand because i
already have the address of a char by
definition
of that star symbol so what's going on
here
let me see now if i run scan f1
what happens so make scan f1
and oh let's see here's a warning i'm
getting variable s is uninitialized when
used here all right that's fine
it wants me to initialize it because
this is a very common mistake those of
you who alluded to segmentation faults
earlier might have encountered something
similar in spirit to this so that
squelched that error let me go ahead and
run
scan f1 alright here we go tj
that is not your name but okay didn't
crash at least it's just a little weird
david null okay that's a little weird
let's go ahead and do this again let's
type in a really
long name
enter damn it that didn't work so
let's try an even longer name
just i'm hitting paste a lot
okay damn it too many times
too many times command not found that's
definitely not a command
wow okay uh
oh that's interesting oh there it is no
same thing
okay so what's actually going on well
null
which is all lowercase here which is
just kind of an aesthetic thing
well it's not working it's not working
well what am i actually doing
in that first line of code when i say
give me s to be a
char star otherwise known as a string
all that's doing is allocating this and
it's technically the size
of a pointer a pointer we never mention
this before but now we can
turns out it is 64 bits or eight
bytes eight bytes is one eight bits is
one byte
so uh pointer is by definition on many
computers these days
most of your macs most of your pcs the
ide the sandbox the lab
is 64 bits so that just means there's 64
bits here but
we initialized it to null so that just
means there's 64 zeros here
dot dot dot but when i get a string
using scanf what i'm telling the
computer to do with this line of code
here notice
is hey computer go to that address and
put a string there
so what's actually happening it turns
out that there's just not enough room to
type in tj
there's not enough room uh that's a bit
of a white lie because we could fit you
in 64 bits but there's not enough room
to type in
the long sentence or paragraph of text i
did right we did what did we not do
we didn't allocate any space over here
all we allocated space for was the
address
and so every time i use scanf saying get
me a string and put it here
there's nowhere to put it and so the
value just very defensively says no like
no
cannot store this anywhere for you so i
actually need to be a little smarter
about this i actually need to get myself
some space so that i can actually store
something in the right place so let's do
that
let me go ahead and create a new program
i'm going to go ahead and call this
scanf 2
thank you we need a little secret code
to remind me of that
scan wrong file name so i'm going to go
ahead and create a file called
scanf2 dot scanf2.c
and i'm going to quickly recreate this
standard io.h
int main void and then down here i'm
going to go ahead and
you know what instead of a string s
which i know today to be a char
star s what is a string really well you
said it earlier what is a string
it's an array of characters let me take
you literally just
give me an array of let's say five
characters the av id
or you know one more that's fine just
enough for my backslash zero
let me just create a string really low
level but this time
give myself the chunk of memory i don't
want just the address of a character
i want the actual characters themselves
let me go ahead and just prompt the
human
for their string with s just like before
then let me call scanf and get a string
from the user using percent s and then
pass in s
and here's a little trick it turns out
that because a string is really just an
array
but a string is also just a pointer you
can actually treat an array as though it
is a pointer in address and so even
though this is a char
s array this is okay this is the
equivalent
in this context of being just the
address of a string because strings
are arrays arrays can be treated as
pointers as of now
and then let me go ahead and just print
out whatever the human typed in s is
actually this
pass in s semicolon save yeah
at this point it would be redundant to
do char star because i literally
want for this story six characters i
want space rather for six
characters so this is kind of week two
stuff now there's no
pointers involved but again just showing
the equivalence of these ideas for now
so if i now go into this and this is in
my other directory at the moment
make scan f2 enter
dot slash scan f2 s is going to type in
i'll type in my name i know i can fit
that
we're back in business like now it's
working because i didn't just create the
address first string i created the space
for the string but
let me get a little dangerous david
malen
okay that kind of worked out okay uh
david
malen or some really long other
name okay that worked out too let me go
ahead and run it again
let me try that really long string again
see what happens
i know this didn't work out very well
last time all right done
oh okay so now i'm in the club of those
of you who have had
segmentation faults so let's understand
what's going on here
segmentation fault a moment ago i
claimed was touching a segment a chunk
of memory that's not your own
so what just happened well with this
simple program i told the computer hey
computer give my
give me six k room for six characters
give me six bytes
with this scanf line i'm telling the
computer put the following
user input at that location in that
array of characters d
a v id backslash zero fit david malin
didn't really but it didn't seem to be a
huge deal david malin or some really
long other
name also didn't crash the computer but
that's because unbeknownst to us
usually when you ask for six bytes the
computer is kind of sort of it's getting
you a few extras it's not safe to use
them
but it gives you enough that you're not
going to necessarily see a problem like
a segmentation fault but it only
allocates a few extra bytes typically
so if you really keep pasting in long
long long long lines of text
eventually you're going to exceed not
only those six bytes but well
past the special the secret bytes that
you got back that you shouldn't be using
anyway
and that point the computer just gives
up and says you are touching memory you
shouldn't
aka segmentation fault
really good question so even though i'm
getting these sort of extra bytes why am
i not seeing them after david
i'm probably getting lucky long story
short when you first run a program
much of the memory that your program has
access to is by default initialized to
zeros
zero is the same thing as backslash zero
and so i'm getting lucky when i have d a
v
id and then excess space in that array a
lot of them are initialized to z
uh zeros already and the string is
getting secretly terminated
for me or the the better answer is
it's undefined behavior like you should
not touch memory that is not your own
what happens after that
is your risk alone but that's a
conjecture as to why that's happening
all right so what is the fundamental
feature then that getstring is providing
for us
all of this time getstring has actually
been dealing with
all of this headache for us i mean
honestly even i'm getting bored like
thinking about talking about how you
just get a damn string from the user
because you need to figure out well how
many bytes do you need and what if the
human types in one more byte than you
were expecting then you need to do a
switcheroo and get more memory
getstring is doing all of this headache
for us
and that's not to say you need to use it
forever they're indeed training wheels
but that's just because when you're
using c or a lot of programming
languages
you the computer will only do what you
tell it to do and it turns out that even
asking the user for input
if you don't know how many characters he
or she is going to type in from
the get-go you have to deal with it and
so underneath the hood and you're
welcome to take a look at the source
code for
cs50s library which i'll post on the
homepage later today
it turns out that the way we're doing
getstring is taking baby steps we
literally like
get one character at a time from the
user kind of building the the road as we
go
and if we don't have enough space we ask
the computer give me some more bytes so
i can get more bytes and we just get one
character at a time so that we can
handle the user maliciously or
accidentally typing in way more input
than we actually expect so
let's contextualize all of this then
recall that we've been drawing these
pictures the past couple of weeks let's
just make this
super clear as to what's been going on
this is a memory
module and a computer it's just a green
board it's way blown out of scale here
it's usually like yay big inside of your
mac or pc
laptop or desktop though it can vary in
size one of these black chips is the
actual memory or the bytes to which
we've been referring and if we zoom in
on that
recall that i proposed last week that
you can just think about this as like a
grid an array
and it doesn't have to be rectangular
this is just an artist's rendition but
each of those squares represents we
claimed a byte
and each of those bytes can be addressed
in some way with a number and that
number is just
its location otherwise known as an
address
we can actually see this it turns out as
follows let me go ahead and open up
this example here or actually you know
let's just write this one from scratch
let me rate a program
called addresses dot c
and that's going to use our our old
friends the cs50 library
and standardio dot h and
in main void and let me go ahead and
just do this i'm going to go ahead and
get a string no you know what no more
string
char star s from the user get string
ask the user for s let me get another
string akh r star
get string call it t from the user and
then
i want to print out not the strings
which i used to do like this
printing out s i want to print out the
pointer
that s really is that is the address
turns out percent p
for pointer will print out not the
string at that memory location
it will print the actual memory location
for you of s
and i can do the same thing here percent
p backslash zero
paste in t and just so i know which is
which let me just prefix it
with some text s colon and t colon let
me go ahead now down here and do make
addresses oh i messed up
missed a semicolon let me do this again
make a
make addresses
and get rid of this that compiled okay
dot slash
addresses and here we go let's type in
oh let's do brian and veronica like
before
enter and this is a little funky but it
turns out the ide
and your macs and your pcs have a lot of
memory so this is the address
it's not quite as small as 100 it's not
quite as small as 900
it's actually kind of big it's a 2 3
3 1 0 1 0 with this weird ox
well turns out this is just a human
convention in week 0 we talked about
decimal and all of us grew up with
decimal ten digits
from zero to nine we talked a little bit
about binary uh zeros and ones
turns out there's an infinite number of
base systems decimal dec
binary bi are just two of those infinite
number of possibilities
turns out there's another one that's
super common called hexadecimal
hexa meaning 16 in this case so base 16
actually has 16 letters in its alphabet
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
a b c d e f
so it turns out that bass systems that
need to count higher
than 10 characters just start using
letters of the alphabet by convention
humans just decided this so we're
getting uh just numbers in this case but
if these addresses were even bigger
we might actually see some alphabetical
letters between zero and f
zero uh between a and f there and
frankly i don't know what address this
is but google's usually pretty good at
this stuff so let me actually
open up another browser window
so google is your friend when it comes
to this stuff or any number of
calculators ox2331010 in
decimal please and google has translated
that so brian
i kind of under bet earlier he's not at
address location
zero he's actually in the 36
millionth byte inside of my computer
right now
location 36 million 900 880 so a little
higher address than 100
and then veronica if we really want to
get into the weeds here
we can say in decimal let google
translate that for us she's at location
36 million 900
944 why who cares the computer is
managing all of this for us but
when getstring used malloc these are
literally the numbers
that were being returned saying you may
use
this chunk of memory and why do humans
use hexadecimal
like it's just slightly more compact to
say oh
x 23 3 1 0 5 0 then 3 6 9
0 0 9 4 4 like you just save a few
digits so it's just conventional that's
all there's no magic there but
recall earlier do you recall that when i
had the debugger open earlier
you saw next to my name variable a value
that was cryptically ox0
and then there was another value that i
don't recall ox something
that was just the numeric address of my
name
in hexadecimal and ox0 is just
the technical address being used by
null yeah
sorry can you say that again
i should have clarified ox humans years
ago decided anytime you see
anything with 0x that means whatever
comes next
is hexadecimal just a convention uh it's
also common too if it starts with a zero
uh it's an octal which is base eight if
you see a lowercase b
at the end it means binary so humans
have just come up with symbologies to
kind of communicate this to readers
that's all
not part of the value so turns out that
we can actually do this math ourselves
and we won't really get into the weeds
of this because it's not
a particularly useful life skill to be
able to convert to various base systems
but let's just do one example so that
we've seen it just to make clear that
there's no magic here it's just a
different way of thinking about numbers
versus grade school so if back in the
day we had three decimal numbers 255 216
and then another 255 if we rewound to
week zero
we could go through the math of
converting that to binary and even if it
might take you a little while this is
the binary
equivalent and frankly the first and
last are kind of easy
255 is kind of a special value because
with eight bits
all of which are one that's what gives
you 255 so the only hard one is actually
this but who cares about the math today
we know from weeks ago that we can do
this if we really tried
but notice that bytes are eight bits
and of course eight has two is a pair of
four
if you will well what's really nice
about hexadecimal
is that it starts at zero and it ends at
f and that's zero one two three four
five six seven eight
nine uh wait yes that's ten okay and
then
a b c d e f i just held up sixteen
fingers in total
hence hexadecimal what's nice about base
16
is that how many bits do i need to count
from zero up to
one two three four fifteen
just four right so if i have all zero
bits that's zero
and if i have four one bits that's uh
give me uh
let's see this is uh an eight plus four
plus two plus one gives me 15. so long
story short hexadecimal is super
convenient
because zero through f maps wonderfully
cleanly
to four bits so it's just a nice way of
thinking about the world not in units of
eight
but in four instead so all i did here
was i took my values and i just added a
little bit of white space to make clear
that eight bits is like a pair of four
bits
it turns out now that one one one one is
f
for the reasons i enumerated earlier all
ones is f
otherwise known as 15. all ones is again
f
otherwise known as 15. if we did the
math 1 1
zero one is d one zero zero zero
is eight and then all ones is f and f so
long story short
there is a way to convert from decimal
to binary to hexadecimal to any number
of other base systems
it all just boils down to what digits
you care about and the way you write
this to your question earlier
is by human convention not just ffd8ff
but ox ffoxd8 oxff
just because then it's clear to the user
what it is so
a little levity now i'm sorry to do this
to you but now you will all hopefully
understand
this famous comic
okay welcome to that club of people who
understands things like this so
let's now stumble upon just one
last problem and we'll take it home by
putting into the context of a very
uh sexy field of forensics where all of
these building blocks will come into
play
but first let's start with a problem
suppose i want to implement a function
here called swap
whose purpose in life is just to swap
two values a and b i just want to do a
switcheroo
let's first do this uh with a sort of
mid-lecture snack for at least one
person would anyone
be up for okay that was fast
volunteering come on up
what's your name kelly all right thank
you for volunteering so suddenly
kelly david nice to meet you okay so
very simple task at hand i have here
two empty cups we have some orange juice
okay put this in here and we've got some
milk
over here should stand out very
different colors
okay i would just like you kelly if you
could
swap those two values orange goes into
milk milk goes into orange please
that is cheating okay um no literally
the cups i put them in the wrong cup i
prefer my milk in the other cup and my
orange juice in the other cup i'm sorry
okay that is not available to you okay
okay so you're struggling why are you
struggling because i'm gonna mix them
and then they it won't be the same right
so i mean obviously like this is not
this is kind of a losing proposition you
can't really do this what would make
this easier for you besides just putting
them back in the bottles
having another container yeah so you
need like a temporary storage space for
this uh you know
let me tear we get some some more cups
over here
ah this will make it easier okay so if i
get you some temporary space here you go
could you solve the problem now please
ah very nice a little
contamination but that's okay uh but i
need that temporary cut back for tara
yeah okay thank you all right a round of
applause if we could for kelly here
we have well here we go i'm guessing you
don't want more milk but orange juice
okay thank you so much
all right so what's the point here this
is pretty easy like once you have some
temporary storage space a variable if
you will like it's no problem to swap
two values
so let me go ahead and do that as
follows i'm gonna go ahead
and just implement this swap function in
c exactly as kelly
ultimately just implemented it if the
goal is to swap a and b
i can't just do a complete switcheroo it
seems i need to put
one of those values like the milk in
another container and then swap and then
swap so it takes three steps not just
one all right so i could call this extra
variable or cup that tara gave us like
anything we want
temp so i'm just going to put a in temp
then i'm going to put b in a because a
is now empty
then i'm going to put temp in b and then
i don't really care what happens to temp
indeed it's just still sitting there
but the job is now done so let's go
ahead and see this program
in action because obviously this should
be pretty straightforward so let me go
ahead
and open up this program in the context
of a main function so we can actually
run it
in this code here i'm going to
demonstrate it as follows here's my main
function
i'm going to call variable x give it 1
call variable y give it 2
go ahead and just print out just for a
quick sanity check x is this
y is that then i'm going to call this
super simple swap function
x comma y then i'm going to print the
exact same thing
x is this y is that just so i can see in
those variables i could also use debug
50 but this is meant to be a complete
solution i want to see it on the screen
here is swap i've copy pasted that from
before this feels like a no-brainer
super straightforward let's go into my
directory
and compile this program which slight
spoiler no swap
is the name dot slash no swap
let's zoom in nope that is not what i
intended right i really intended milk to
become oj oj to become milk or x become
y
y become x this doesn't seem to work and
again
the only magic is this one call to swap
all right maybe it just works some of
the time so
nope nope okay now it's time for the
debugger i don't understand what's going
on in my program printf
is not really illuminating here so let
me go ahead and run debug 50. no swap
the little debugging panel is going to
open on the side but wait i need a break
point
i'm going to start a break point at the
very top the first line i care about i
don't really care about all the stuff at
the super top
now i'm going to go ahead and rerun
debug 50 no swap all right
now i see over here the first line nine
is highlighted
notice on the right hand side and this
perhaps answers by example your question
earlier
x and y conveniently but just because
we're initialized to zero
not by me i shouldn't necessarily trust
this in all contexts but that's why they
had values
they're otherwise known as garbage
values but i got lucky with zeros here
let me go ahead and step over that line
and if you watch albeit small on the
right hand side
x should suddenly take on a value of one
and if i step over one more line y
should take on a value of
two okay so i'm pretty confident program
is thus far correct
i'm going to go ahead and step over
printf and notice the blue terminal
window i see one output
now things get interesting if i continue
stepping over
lines it's just going to finish running
and i it's not enough
so notice this time i'm going to hover
over this third icon step into
now i can kind of go down the rabbit
hole so to speak and go
into the swap function and notice the
debugger jumps into that other function
so here now the context changed my local
variables are now
a b and temp and this is really weird a
is 1 b is 2 as expected because i passed
in
x comma y and in the context of this
function i'm just calling them a comma b
because but why is temp 32
767 it's just because it can't be
trusted it's a garbage value if you just
give yourself
a temporary value who knows what's in
there we got lucky and tara did not have
anything in this cup but it could have
had a garbage value maybe it had some
pepsi
and then we would have had to replace
that value somehow so to be clear
when you declare variables in a program
quite often they have garbage values
just
bogus values the zeros and ones that are
there underneath the hood in that chip
but that you didn't set yourself but
that's okay because i'm explicitly in
this next line
setting temp equal to a so it doesn't
matter what its original weird value was
so if i click next temp is now 1
aka a now notice a is going to become b
if you watch the right hand side
now i seem to have a is 2 b is 2 which
is a little worrisome but not as bad
because i have that separate variable
temp so i still have the one around so
now
b is about to become one and i've done
the switcheroo okay at this point in the
story line 22
my code seems correct b has become a a
has become b
and the values are swapped and the
debugger is confirming that for me
visually
so now let's do a step
and dammit
lost what is going on
intuitively even if you've never seen c
or done this before like
clearly there's a bug why is
what is that bug what must be happening
yeah
yeah what seems to be happening here is
yes you're passing in x and y and
calling it a and b
but a and b would seem to be copies of x
and y
and i am very successfully very
correctly swapping a
and b but because they're copies it has
no effect on the original x and y so our
metaphor here of juice isn't quite apt
because uh i didn't pass kelly copies of
the oj in milk i handed her the actual
oj and milk and she was able to
change the values but in the context of
c and code when you pass arguments to a
function you're passing copies of those
arguments to the function
so intuitively what is the solution we
clearly cannot pass from one function to
another
copies of the values if we expect the
function swap or aka
kelly to make some useful change for us
what do we have to pass
to the function or to kelly instead
the addresses of those values right i
told her
where the milk and oj were i didn't give
her copies of them i told her here's the
milk here's the oj swap those in this
version of the code i've just said
here's a copy of x here's a copy of y
you can call them a and b we need to now
use the ampersand or something like that
to pass in
a map if you will the treasure map to
those values
so that swap can change the original
values and the way we do this is a
little weird looking
but all we're going to have to do
is make a little addition here that
looks as
follows it's got to look like this
instead so this is the broken version
or broken in that it doesn't have the
effect we intend even though it's
works this is what we need to do instead
and it's the last piece of new symbology
for today
we've seen star in a couple different
places before now we're using it in one
final context
when you specify a star here and here
in the arguments to a function that is
just the way you tell the computer
i'm expecting not an int but the address
of an int i'm expecting not an int here
but the address of an n so
two pointers two addresses of integers
down here
temp is still just an inst i don't need
to overthink temp that's just an empty
cup give me an integer called temp
from week one but what do i want to
store in temp
both a and b in this version are
addresses do i want to remember the
address of a
the address a and the address b no i
want to remember the volume of oj the
volume of milk i want to remember
one and two i don't care where in memory
they are
so star in this context when there's no
mention of a data type
there's just a star and a variable name
that variable is a pointer and it's not
multiplication there's no math going on
that star is the d reference operator
that says go to this address and get the
value there
so if this address a is at location i
don't know 100 like brian was
and this address b is at location 900
like veronica was
star a means go to the 100th byte in
memory
and get me that value which is one this
means
down here go to the address b get me
that value at address 900 which is
two and go ahead and store one in temp
go ahead and go to that address and put
whatever's at b's address so get that
address and put it over
get that address get the value and put
it over at that address
by dereferencing and then lastly go to b
in memory like over there put the temp
value there
so whereas ampersand in our previous
example means tell me what the address
is of a variable star is the opposite
when you have an address it says
go to that address follow the treasure
map x marks the spot
at that location in memory and get at
its value
so what is the net effect here if i
actually now open up
not this example but swap.c
spoiler this one's going to actually
work if i open up swap.c
we're going to see now the following
instead the code is almost the same
except that i've pasted in this new
green version of the function
and notice here this had a change why am
i typing in
ampersand x now and ampersand y instead
of
just x and y
exactly the swap function now the new
and improved version is expecting two
addresses
stars inch stars aka pointers
not just values so this means i know x
and y are actually integers from week
one
now i need the address of x and the
address of y so that
swap can follow those treasure maps so
to speak and go to those addresses
so now when i run this program this is
more like the metaphor with kelly
where i told her where the milk and oj
were now swap can go to those locations
as follows make swap
let me go ahead and then do dot slash
swap enter
ah now it seems to be working and we can
see as much even with the debugger even
though it doesn't seem to be buggy i can
still use debug 50
to see and understand my program if not
obvious
oh i still need a break point let's set
a breakpoint as before let's rerun debug
50.
the right-hand panel will open
automatically for me
and let's go ahead and see if i start
stepping over this
now i see that x
is 1 y is 2
printf prints as much in the screen now
i'm going to go ahead and step
into swap and now notice it's a little
weird looking
because now a is an address and b is an
address but temp is still an int with a
garbage value but i can fix that
now temp is one but notice a and b's
values are not changing but what is
clearly changing
per the code
so notice this is weird and cryptic a is
this ox value that's a big hexadecimal
address like that is where in memory a
is but you know what if i click the
little triangle i can kind of follow
that pointer and go to it the debugger
is smart like that
so star a go to a is two and star b
at the moment is two but if i keep going
now
i've done a switcheroo and you can see
that these values have changed
and again we don't care what these
addresses are i don't care what the
actual addresses are
i do care that it gives me this
functionality because now when i return
up here in print
now the values have indeed changed as i
expected this whole time
all right that was complex but
hopefully clear as to why it now works
even though we've made this code look
more cryptic
if not any questions are welcome yeah
good question do we really need to have
these semi uh these ampersands here
because we already have the stars here
show an answer yes for symmetry this is
telling the function what to expect on
the way in
this is what's telling swap telling uh
the computer actually what to send in
so it's what are the actual inputs to
that function
has to be symmetric
we are swapping what is at the addresses
okay
uh short answer you cannot it for the
following
reason so technically when you do
ampersand x and ampersand y these are
converted to the address of x the
address of y
technically swap is getting copies of
something c
has not changed but c is now getting
copies
of the address of x copies of the
address
of y calling them a and b so sure you
could swap the addresses but for the
same reasons as before it's going to
have no fundamental effect
the difference here is because i'm
passing in a map so to speak to x and y
their addresses and again an address is
like we are at 45
what quincy street i think right now
cambridge massachusetts o2 138 usa that
uniquely identifies the building
these ox hexadecimal numbers uniquely
identify locations in memory
so this is like saying now get me the
address of x get me the address of y
and i'm technically passing in copies of
those addresses but it doesn't matter
because now with the star notation i'm
saying go to those addresses
and swap who is physically in this
building and some other
other all right so let's just put this
now into the context of what else your
computer actually has just so that
you've seen some nomenclature
around this computer's memory so this is
the chip with a grid laid out on top of
it just to communicate that there's
bytes here and we could number them but
let's think about this now more
abstractly
and let me just reveal that it turns out
that the computer treats different bytes
different squares
in different ways just by convention it
turns out that in your computer's memory
and this is all just an artist's
representation at the top
of that chip of memory so to speak is
the so-called text of your program this
is a fancy and non-obvious way
of saying the zeros and ones that your
code have been
has been compiled into the text of a
program is the code you wrote
in binary that's where it's loaded from
memory so in mac os and windows you
double click an icon
that program is loaded into memory i
said last week it's literally loaded
into
the top of your computer's memory
conceptually
what else well the heap is the fancy
name given to the chunk of memory
in which uh memory is coming from when
you call malloc so when i called malloc
earlier to get a bunch of space for some
characters
it was just coming from this big open
area called the heap and that's what
getstring is using and
other functions as well well it turns
out that the reason for the problem we
just ran into
is because the bottom part of memory is
what's called the stack
the stack is the area of memory that
functions use
when they are called and this is
actually relevant to that very simple no
swap example
as follows if we now assume that anytime
you call a function
the memory it uses comes from the bottom
of that big block of memory
we can draw that for instance here on
the screen because it turns out that
anytime you call a function your that
function gets a slice of its own memory
so for instance main is always the first
program call function called and so
it gets the first slice of memory at the
bottom of the screen here
and so if main had two variables x and y
that's like saying
okay give me a chunk of memory called x
and put the value 1 in it give me
another chunk of memory call it
y put a value in it here but remember
from the first
no swap example the swap function was
called
this is a stack in the literal sense you
go into a dining hall cafeteria one
tray for the food goes on another goes
on another goes on another so that the
humans can take it and put food in place
on it
well similarly in this model when you
call a function it gets its own slice of
memory but literally above
conceptually the existing uh frame on
the stack
so this is the swap function's own chunk
of memory
and it too gets some space it gets some
space for a variable called a
it gets some space for a variable called
b and guess what goes inside those with
that first example
a copy of x and a copy of y
and you know what it had a temp variable
so that's got to have some space here
so i'll call this tmp and recall that i
set temp equal to a
so that got 1. and then what happened
well then i did
what uh star what did i uh
let me get this right uh
we had a gets b so what happened there
so in this example here a gets the value
b
so that changed and then what happened
here b got the value of temp so that
changed
so swap was working in the sense that it
was swapping values but the problem is
when a function returns this chunk of
memory that it was previously using
gets reclaimed so that someone else can
now use it
another function so we did all that hard
work and no swap
and we did it correctly we just did it
in the wrong place
so by contrast this next example that we
did
which was swap.c just treated the memory
a little bit differently main this time
still had two variables called x and
this was a one
and then another one called y and this
was a two
and then when swap was called this time
it again had a variable called a
and a variable called b but what was
stored in a and b
well now they're addresses and i don't
know what it is but let me just
arbitrarily say that this is location
100
this is location let's say 104
but it could be anything we just don't
care at this point and it would have ox
technically if the computer were showing
us
what's going in a here is 100 what's
going in b
here is 104 and those
are the addresses of x and y and the
code we had using all of those new stars
was saying go to address uh 100
and store whatever is at address 100
in temp then go to the address that's in
b
or 104 and store that at the location
in star a whatever is there then it was
saying go get that temp value by the way
and go ahead and put that here
so that now we did different work in a
different place
so now when swap is done running it
doesn't matter if its memory disappears
because it has now mutated or changed
the other memory that it was passed in
just like kelly changed or mutated the
cups i
actually pointed her at rather than
copies thereof
now as an aside there's other chunks of
memory that are actually used
if you have global variables in a
program turns out that in between the
text and the heap memory
are your global variables if they're
initialized with values or they're not
initialized with values as would happen
with the equal sign
but we don't care too much about that
for today's purposes and if you've ever
heard of environment variables which we
will
when we get to web programming they too
are stored elsewhere in memory but the
most interesting chunks of memory are
stack
and heap as in this case here but
unfortunately it's so easy for things to
go awry i mean some of you experience
segmentation faults already and let's
consider
why that might happen so here's a
contrived example of code
that is by design buggy but let's just
talk it through in english what these
lines are doing
this line here int star x is saying hey
computer
give me a variable that will store the
address of an
integer so give me a pointer to an int
is the more casual way of saying it
hey computer give me another variable
that's going to store the address of an
ant and call it y so x and y
that's it this line is newish hey
computer allocate enough space that will
fit in int
so sizeofint is the new syntax we saw
earlier for just figuring out how many
bytes is an int odds are this is going
to come back as 4
or 32 bits in most computers so this
just says hey browser give me four bytes
of memory
and store that in this location
or rather store that in this variable
store that in this variable
so maybe it's going to say okay here's
four bytes at location 100 or here's
four bytes at location 900 or wherever
we don't care
we're just remembering that address in x
star x
says go to that address 100 or 900
whatever it is
put the number 42 there this next line
says
go to the address in y and put the
unlucky number intent
13 there
well what is the address in y
i haven't allocated it yet what's the
address in x it's wherever malloc
told me to use space that's safe that
was like 100 900 whatever the value was
but did i allocate space for
y so what kind of value does it contain
so to speak
a garbage value maybe it's zero maybe
it's like 32
000. we don't know because if you don't
specify the value
it is not safe to trust it or do
anything with it
this is going to give me probably one of
those segmentation faults and indeed if
i run a program like this
i'm quite likely going to see exactly
that kind of problem
it's perhaps better though to see this
in a way that'll paint a more memorable
picture and for that
thought we'd take oh in our 10 minutes
remaining use a few of these minutes to
take a look at something our friends at
stanford put together
with a bit of claymation it's about
three minutes long well worth it to
paint a picture of exactly what goes
wrong when you don't
use memory correctly if we could dim the
lights
[Music]
hey binky wake up it's time for pointer
fun
what's that learn about pointers oh
goody well to get started i guess we're
gonna need a couple pointers
okay this code allocates two pointers
which can point to integers
okay well i see the two pointers but
they don't seem to be pointing to
anything
that's right initially pointers don't
point to anything the things they point
to are called pointees
and setting them up's a separate step oh
right right i knew that the pointies are
separate
so how do you allocate a point e okay
well this code allocates a new integer
point e
and this part sets x to point to it
hey that looks better so make it do
something okay
i'll de-reference the pointer x to store
the number 42 into its point e
for this trick i'll need my magic wand
of dereferencing
your magic wand of dereferencing
that that's great this is what the code
looks like
i'll just set up the number and hey look
there it goes so doing a d reference on
x follows the arrow to access its point
e in this case the store 42 in there
hey try using it to store the number 13
through the other pointer
why okay i'll just go over here to y
and get the number 13 set up and then
take the wand of dereferencing
and just oh hey that didn't work
say uh binky i don't think dereferencing
y is a good idea because uh
you know setting up the point is a
separate step and i don't think we ever
did it
good point yeah we allocated the pointer
y but we never set it to point to a
point d
very observant hey you're looking good
there binky
can you fix it so that y points to the
same point e as x
sure i'll use my magic wand of pointer
assignment
is that gonna be a problem like before
no this doesn't touch the pointees
it just changes one pointer to point to
the same thing as another
oh i see now y points to the same place
as x
so so wait now y is fixed it has a point
e so you can try the wand of d
referencing again to send the 13 over
uh okay here it goes
hey look at that now dereferencing works
on y and because the pointers are
sharing that one point
e they both see the 13. yeah sharing uh
whatever
so are we gonna switch places now oh
look we're out of time
but so hopefully that puts a little more
visual behind
some of these ideas but let's now
contextualize this
uh in a domain that's perhaps more
familiar um
in a couple of ways so one some of you
might already know especially if you
have prior programming experience of a
very popular website called stack
overflow where lots of programmers post
questions
uh and hopefully answers to common
technical problems
if you ever wondered why it's called
stack overflow it turns out it reduces
to this picture here
this was not a mistake that i drew one
arrow from the heap pointing down
and one arrow from the stack growing up
as you malloc malloc malloc
more and more space starts up here so to
speak and you just get more and more
space that's going this direction
but the more functions you call function
after function after function after
function each of them gets its own slice
or frame of memory
that too is growing up so this feels
like a pretty bad design but honestly
it's not really avoidable because if you
have a finite amount of memory you can't
avoid
each other forever and so there's this
fundamental risk
of overflowing the stack or even
overflowing the heap in the reverse
direction so stack overflow is an
allusion to
for instance calling too many many many
many many many many functions so many so
that it overlaps
other chunks or segments of memory
thereby inducing
a segmentation fault and buffer uh heap
overflow is in the reverse direction and
these are more generally known as
buffer overflows and we'll see more of
these in the
the weeks to come but now that we have
the ability to discuss pointers let's
introduce one final feature
and then a familiar face so it turns out
that you can actually come up with your
own custom variables
kind of like we did with string but even
more sophisticated than that
for instance if i wanted to implement a
program that involves multiple students
i might do something like this ask the
user what is the enrollment in a class
then go ahead and give myself an array
of strings akhr stars today
of that size and then i could also have
another array of dorms and i could have
two
arrays containing one for the students
names one for the student's dorms
and i could keep track of other things
another array for emails another array
for phone numbers
but this gets messy quickly because you
can imagine if i need name
names and dorms and emails and phones
that starts to become a lot of copy
paste
and i just have this design where i have
lots and lots of arrays
where each bracket location like bracket
zero bracket one
presumably refers to the same student
across all of these arrays like
messy messy messy design so with the
wave of my hand let me actually fix that
immediate problem out of the gate by
introducing a new feature
i can invent my own data types let me
just go ahead and declare an array
called students
with this many students but of data type
student c comes with float bool char
int not string and definitely not
student so you can make your own custom
data types
and you can put them in your own header
files which we've not done either
but i can look and you'll see more of
this in the next problem set
so not to worry if this feels quite
brief it's just meant to be a teaser
here
instruct.h is how you declare or define
your own type the keyword is literally
type def
struct for structure or data structure
to be more complete
the name of the data structure comes at
the end after some curly braces
and then inside the curly braces you
just specify well what do you want a
student to have
i want them to have a name a dorm maybe
a phone number maybe an email address
anything i want
i can just add here so that now in my
actual code
i can have an array of actual students
and i can just access them with this new
notation like this
you know that you can index into an
array with bracket notation
what you didn't know until now perhaps
is that if that
at that location is a structure aka
struct
you can get at the name the dorm or the
phone or the email or anything else
there just by using a dot
notation which is our last piece of new
syntax for today
everything else is the same i can write
a program that says so and so is in such
and such a dorm
by just saying get the ith student's
name and the ith student's dorm
and i can be even fancier and if i don't
want to just print those values i can
even
now that i see no understand pointers or
i've seen pointers and will soon
understand them
by way of problem sets and practice i
can actually do this
this is just a little sneak preview of a
line of code that uses a new function
called
f open f open is file open and it takes
in the name of the file to open you
might know of csv files they're like
simple spreadsheets comma
separated values and quote unquote w
means write so this says open the file
called students.csv
in write mode so i can write to this
file because in this example as you'll
see
in the days to come i want to write out
to a file but it turns out to use files
i need to know what a pointer is and
it's a little weird that it's all caps
but there is a data type in c
called file and it's a pointer so long
story short what you're going to see in
the next problem set as we explore the
world of forensics is the ability using
pointers and a few new functions
to open files and get back the address
of that file in memory
so that you can go to that address
change the contents of a file
and save it back out all of us take for
granted these days that you can go to
file open and file save but what's
actually happening
pointers are involved stuff's getting
loaded into memory and the computer is
dereferencing or going to those
addresses
and changing what's at those locations
in memory now why might you want to do
this well here of course is a milo you
might recall from some of the problem
sets and the walkthroughs
turns out we could try to enhance this
picture of her by zooming in
and here's about as much fidelity as it
is in her
eyes like i do not see the glint of any
uh
criminal's logo on his or her jacket in
the glint of zamila's eyes if you zoom
in on an image and an image recall from
week zero is just a grid
of pixels or dots that's all you get and
you can maybe smooth it out a little bit
or clean up the colors but you can't
just
enhance quote unquote and see more of
the glint in zamayla's eye because an
image at the end of the day is just a
bit map a map top down left right
of pixels for instance here's a smiley
face if you kind of take a look back and
you can kind of see a black smiley face
against a white backdrop
and if we just decide as humans let's
represent white dots with ones
and black dots with zeros this might be
what's in the file
this is what the human sees so if we
have the ability to open that
from a file store it in memory and then
using pointers go
to those locations in memory we can even
change the smiley face to an unhappy
face for instance or color it or do any
number
of things to it now at quick glance
there's a lot going on in files
because what a file is is a set of
conventions that humans decided on where
humans years ago just decided in a
bitmap file bmp file it's an
older but still popular file format for
images humans just decided that like
we're going to put a bunch of special
values at the first bytes of the file
then some more special values than the
actual
r g b pixels
in the rest of the file so this is
mental or cryptic at first glance and
the next homework assignment will walk
you through this
but all it is is a convention of what
the zeros and ones mean
in these different locations and indeed
the challenge ahead is going to be to do
a number of things one is to first and
foremost figure out
who done it a sort of murder mystery in
which there's a clue hidden in an image
but an image that's a little noisy and
you're going to have to figure out what
secret message is in the image by
loading that image in
tweaking it putting a sort of red filter
on top of it and seeing the secret
message but all digitally
to actually resizing images and taking
this many pixels and this big of a
smiley face or something else
and making it bigger or more comfortable
making it even smaller and figuring out
how to make that
work out and then lastly we've been
taking some photographs of all of cs50
staff in cambridge and new haven
uh unfortunately we accidentally uh
corrupted or lost the memory card but we
made a forensic image of it a copy
of all of the zeros and ones with all of
the staff photos and we're going to need
you to write code
that actually recovers all of the jpegs
or photographs
from that digital card by opening a file
reading in those zeros and ones
understanding what they are and where
they are and just writing them back out
to disk using functions we'll introduce
you to
in the problem set itself but of course
all of this takes for granted that we
can do this and you can only do so much
and indeed this week is as much about
solving those problems as it is
realizing the limitations of computers
and so we thought we'd end with the
final few seconds
of this very real example from futurama
magnify that death sphere
[Music]
why is it still blurry that's all the
resolution we have
making it bigger doesn't make it clearer
it does on csi miami
and that's it for cs50 we'll see you
next time